[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELLIOT HUGHES: Hi, my
name's Elliot Hughes.
I've worked on Android
for a while now,
and actually, my
first job on Android
was working on the
Java core libraries
and actually cleaning up
some of the bugs in our JNI.
So first off, I'll show
you what you're probably
expecting to see when you think
JNI, which is code that looks
like this, and I'm
guessing no one can
tell that the code that
actually does anything useful
isn't on that screen yet.
And I'm guessing that no one
can tell me within five seconds
where the useful line
in that either is.
So this is-- this talk is
basically how to not do that.
How do we get away from that?
And the one line answer
is use C++ better.
If you-- if you're
using the C APIs, which
is what most people
do, it's really tricky.
You end up with a sort
of Go To Fail style,
or you have this nested IF
style that we had there.
And there are a lot
of special cases
as well, like I'm trying
to throw an exception,
but there's already
an exception pending.
What do I do there?
How do I chain that
to be the cause
of the previous exception?
So don't write that in
every single JNI method.
Write that once.
And in particular,
have classes that let
you use a string as a string--
use a J string as
if it's a substring.
Similar for arrays--
you don't want
to be having to deal
with a J byte array
when you could just
use operator square
brackets to just use
it like a normal array.
Local references,
too, and there's
a long list of other things.
But the strings and
primitive arrays, I think,
are the two major ones.
Most of the benefit
you get is from that.
Exceptions-- harder
than they look,
and the sort of raw
primitives you get in JNI
are not super useful.
The-- they expect you to
find the class yourself.
They expect you to
create an instance.
If you want to actually
include a proper detail
message or a cause, you end
up doing weird things like,
I need to find the
constructor for my--
for this exception, and
then I need to invoke the--
blah, blah, blah.
It's a lot of code,
especially if you
deal with special cases,
so having a function that
just takes a PRINTF style
format string is a huge relief,
and great.
So I've been talking about
this kind of in the abstract.
I've been saying, you
should do these things.
There are many choices
that you can use for this,
and I think a problem
a lot of people
have is they get hung up on
what's the exact perfect way
to do this.
What's the best?
Doesn't matter.
Any of these are better than
writing the kind of code
that we saw on the
first couple of slides.
Android itself uses
Lib Native Helper,
which you can find in AOSP.
It's in the root directory.
There's a bunch of
header only stuff
for doing the things
I've been talking about,
or if you don't like any of
the others on the internet,
you can just write your own.
That-- they're
really not that hard.
So what does it look like
if you actually do switch
to using something like this?
This is the same code.
This is the same two slides
that we had before, now
condensed to one.
I think five seconds
is plenty of time
for you to actually see
which is the line that
actually does the work there.
You can make this shorter.
You don't actually need to
have the style where we have
the constructors, and then we
check did that actually work
if you're prepared to use C++
exceptions and do some kind
of transformation, but
that's a more advanced topic.
I think this gets you 90% of the
benefit for 20% of the effort,
so this is what Android
does internally.
This is actually
what the code looks
like in Android for that call.
So that was a
really simple thing
where there really
was just one line
of active ingredient in there,
but this scales really well.
And our recommendation
is that you actually--
you try to keep
your code like that,
so don't mix all
the JNI boilerplate
stuff in with your actual code.
Keep those separate in the
same way that you wouldn't--
on the other end
of the spectrum,
if you wouldn't
mix your business
logic and your UI
rendering stuff.
Down here, it's
similar sort of advice.
Don't do that.
Again, if you want
a good example
of this, the Android
system OS class,
is implemented exactly this way.
The implementation's super
repetitive, really boring,
and that's the way we like it.
It's hard to make mistakes.
I'm running out of
time, so I'll just
go through this very quickly.
If you need to worry about
old Android releases,
and you have multiple SO files,
that can get very tricky.
We recommend that you
consider the ReLinker project.
You can find that on Github.
The storing SO
file's uncompressed.
That was mentioned
earlier in the keynote.
One big library is
generally better
than lots of small libraries.
Thank you.
If you have questions,
come and find me.
I'll be in-- I'll be doing
open hours all afternoon.
So thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]